220 000 appareils électro-ménagers
pourront-ils être réparés chaque année
le groupe Fnac Darty c'est doté d'un
nouveau site de près de 8000 mètres
carrés situés à Saint-Pierre-des-Corps
c'est le plus grand de l'enseigne en
France dédié à la réparation les 120
salariés actuels ils traitent des
commandes de tout le grand ouest 30
emplois supplémentaires seront créés
d'ici 2025 visitent avec Léa Turquie
rien ne se jette tout se répare voilà le
nouveau local du groupe Fnac Darty ici
on prévoit de dépanner 220 000 appareils
par an les techniciens de l'atelier
petit électroménagers s'affairent et
pour cause ils font plus de la moitié
des réparations totales pour réparer en
moyenne on est sur un délai d'une
dizaine de jours la plus grosse partie
sur l'atelier effectivement c'est la
famille aspirateur et la famille
expresso broyeur des objets du quotidien
de tout le grand ouest qui trouve une
seconde vie à Saint-Pierre-des-Corps un
atelier de près de 8000 mètres carrés le
plus grand de dédiée à la réparation
pour s'adapter notamment aux nouvelles
habitudes le premier réflexe c'est de
dépanner pour ne pas jeter l'élément
principal de ce qu'on essaie de faire
chez un Darty c'est ça allonger les
durées la durée de vie des produits
qu'on vend en vendant les produits les
plus fiables en réparant les produits
quand ils tombent en panne et en faisant
en sorte que quand ils sont
irrécupérables on les recycle et ceux
qui sont récupérables on les met en
vente dans un mode second vie des
produits d'occasion reconditionnés et
donc vendus moins cher un point positif
pour le porte-monnaie et aussi pour la
planète on a moins d'impact
environnemental de l'activité humaine et
on ne peut pas faire ça absolument
partout parce qu'il faut de la
technicité il faut des systèmes mais le
faire à un endroit qui est un endroit
central comme la Touraine c'est quelque
chose qui va dans de très bon sang donc
c'est intéressant ça montre je crois le
le l'orientation vers laquelle on doit
aller on doit changer le modèle de
développement aujourd'hui le site compte
120 salariés avec un objectif de 150 en